كانت إسرائيل تهاجم
أهدافًا إيرانية في سوريا
أه كثيرًا
على أساس أسبوعي يُعتقد على نطاق واسع
أن إسرائيل نفذت هجمات كبيرة في
إيران داخل تفجيرات إيران
وهجمات شبه عسكرية وهذا
الهجوم بالذات
يناسب النمط الذي
يحاول رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي القيام
به  لاستفزاز إيران حقًا للرد
، وفي النهاية إطلاق مواجهة أمريكية
أه إيرانية قبل
نهاية هذه الإدارة
في الخمسين يومًا القادمة لأن
رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي ودول أخرى
في المنطقة قلقون بشكل أساسي من
أن الإدارة الأمريكية
القادمة
ستشرك إيران على الأرجح  ومحاولة إنقاذ
الصفقة النووية ،
لذا فإن الخمسين يومًا القادمة ما تراه
في سوريا
داخل إيران واغتيال
كبار العلماء النوويين الإيرانيين يتناسب مع
نمط إستراتيجية إسرائيل هو دفع
إيران حقًا إلى الحائط
أه إيران إلى الخلف  الجدار
وإجبارها على الانتقام من وجهة
نظري بولا هو أن إيران أظهرت
قدرًا كبيرًا من ضبط النفس  قادة نيان
لا يريدون حقًا توفير
ما قبل الضرائب والذخيرة
لإدارة ترامب لتنفيذ هجمات
مدمرة
مدمرة ضد
صواريخهم النووية والباليستية
وما يمكن أن يغير هذه الحسابات بالنسبة
لهم فواز هذا ما أريد أن أعرفه
لأنه كذلك  من الواضح أن إيران لديها الكثير
لتكسبه من إدارة بايدن هنا ،
لكنها ليست صفقة منتهية ولن تكون
صفقة جديدة ،
كما تعلم ، لقد تحدثنا رامين وطهران
عن القواعد الشعبية بشكل صحيح ومدى
صعوبة
ذلك في إيران  بالعودة إلى
الطاولة مع حكومة
أمريكية أي حكومة أمريكية أه أنت محق تمامًا أه يعني أي نوع من الصفقة بين إدارة بايدن
وإيران سيكون صعبًا للغاية بالنظر إلى
ما حدث
أه في العام الماضي أه أو  لذلك نحن لا
نتحدث فقط عن
مقتل كبار العلماء الإيرانيين بل نتحدث أيضًا
عن
اغتيال الجنرال الإيراني الكبير سليماني إذا
سألتني حقًا عن الصورة الكبيرة.
لقد حصلت على التفاصيل من مراسلي
الريبو العديدين الخاصين بك
في الميدان إذا سألتني
الصورة الكبيرة التي
سنقوم بها كمؤرخين ويمكن أن أكون مخطئًا
سينظر المؤرخون إلى هذه
الفترة بالذات حول الإدارة الرابحة
لأننا نقول أن بعض الإجراءات تؤدي
إلى عكس ذلك  نتائج
من نتائجها المقصودة
وما قد تكون العواقب غير المقصودة
هي أن الإدارة الرابحة
تنسحب من الاتفاق النووي مع
إيران الذي وقع عليه الرئيس
أوباما باغتيال الجنرال سليماني
والآن باغتيال إسرائيل
أه تعرف فخري زادة العالم
الأعلى
ستفعل ذلك.  ليس فقط
لتعقيد العلاقات الإيرانية ، سننظر إلى
هذه الفترة بالذات على
أنها نقطة تحول في الأساس في
تسريع حصول إيران على قنبلة ذرية.